so we're going up the California coast
right now to try the best coolest cheese
in California the amount that I actually
know about this is almost 0% I just said
yes without knowing what it meant we're
driving up the coast we're about to eat
crazy quantities of cheese in three days
whoa I just walked outside the gas
station this is what Liz doing well when
you sit for so long you have to you have
to work your legs I didn't have sand
right now do it okay so we're about to
pull up the stepladder ranch what's the
deal with what's the deal with this
place so this is a small goat farm it's
where the last remaining ones and they
make this cheese with beer that I really
want to try ready dates of cheese cheese
let's see some - Wow this is crazy
[Music]
stinky in a good way though it's like
when you open up a container for
mozzarella it's like a little bit like a
part but you're a little excited Wow
could have been a cheese made in my
other life you really are meant to be a
cheese made it's a farm
this is a cheese Trier we're gonna take
it in the atrium and try it out looks
like something out no sector human body
yeah oh this is both my dreams and
nightmares yes crazy
basically this guy's about a year old so
this is one of our wheels of clothbound
cheddar oh my
if I were drunk I would be all the time
drinkin and cheese and dangerous ah
yours for series oh my god she is so
[ __ ] good dude like you look a tiger
like that's disgusting and can you eat
this yeah that's amazing nothing better
than beer and cheese is beer n cheese
yeah together
this is our Riley run we'll wash it and
The Libertines stays on once you add the
beer to it it really brings the funk out
a little stinky a little fruity little
kinds of stuff like this like please
thank you whoa ooh did you get the rind
there's so much of that beer taste at
the end could totally see it like mixed
into a grilled cheese filling onto mac &
cheese lemon on the ultimate cheese a
road trip is literally the ultimate
cheese road trip when you first said
ultimate cheese road trip I didn't think
about how many farms and how much cow
poop it would involve yeah I was
thinking we would stop at nice cheese
shops come to Whole Foods we're like out
in the boondocks
we're doing it real we are going to a
cheese making class it was like
literally a cow outside your window I
know
[Music]
this is a cheese that we're making today
this is Branka Branka again it's a blend
of both go and palace milk it smells
great in here so stinky and amazing
we're about to dip in those lemon caper
Liz is chomping at the bit
whoa yeah wait that is amazing we have a
blend of both goat and cow's milk have
you ever just like taken aback and then
he'll add the rennet stir it in within
20 minutes it'll be completely gelled up
like a jello you can like smell the
creaminess of it yeah for at least 20
minutes hold straight oh it's thick Wow
it is oh I see we're gonna touch it it
looks like tofu to me oh it's warm
you're gonna scoop up some curds
Elizabeth come on oh I'm scared
it's like it's like gold baby you got it
water way yeah it's wait this is from
start-to-finish creamy cheese we made
cheese cheers Cheers
cheese love it we are heading up to
Point Reyes Creamery so I know how much
you love blue cheese
I do love blue cheese I hate blue cheese
I don't for blue cheese
they have great blue cheese yes oh my
god you sure blue cheese is made with
penicillin like actual medicine that
doesn't fries because that's what tastes
like oh my name is Sir
waha Merlin we are in Point Reyes
farmstead cheese company and we'll be
tasting our cheese's today right so what
is this one called
so this one is Thomas oh it's very soft
um you know you basically when you taste
cheese you want to smell it and you can
see that you know the texture is very
elastic so you will have a texture of
kind of a very creamy Havarti and Babloo
actually is I like to call it a gateway
okay so if I tried this in a series me
be able to like blue cheese not a lot of
honey
cheers Cheers I like blue cheese I think
I could actually finish this bite but
that's probably like the first blue
cheese I've ever eaten that I've
actually liked so the first favorite
blue cheese this is a Marine French
cheese company and they have a beautiful
little lake by their memory have you had
enough keys yet today Ashley oh my god
we've had so much cheese people keep
asking me where we've been and I have no
idea cheese cheese stop eating it it's
good sharing a hotel room with list
tonight abrasions on you all night my
god please literally is a dream I mean I
need a vegetable I haven't even been
whooping we just got back in the car
after dinner burger and we're
immediately roll down the windows cuz
well like a thousand far it smells like
an [ __ ] so we are driving up to the
farm and just saw a bunch of freaking
Buffalo those are not cows just so we de
switch it up a little bit today
cheese adventure we're gonna move them
over to the street pasture so they can
have breakfast great how do we get down
there ATV
oh my God look at all so they're
basically just going to come across here
and go over there for lunch let's go get
lunch like I do when I want lunch this
is much like lunch at our office here we
go
we're gonna milk water buffalo these are
water buffalo they are from Southeast
Asia
so pinch I can't do it you can fly
scratching your head and rubbing your
belly
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
also just snorted Cheers
so the lady made cheese I love it mm-hmm
oh my goodness the other cheeses that
we've been eating like you kind of want
them paired with something but I feel
like mozzarella is one that like it's
better fresher with just a little bit on
it I could really taste the freshness in
it too like it feels like it was like
just made it's a nice dress made what
I've gotten from this is that buffalo
make incredible cheese but they're
amazing animals it was amazing I thought
it was really cool to see how the cheese
is made we tasted a lot of great cheese
but I think like all great things a
clever thing us yeah everything in
moderation much of my last slide
cheese road trip yeah oh my god no more
dairy on our next road trip please
[Music]
Oh